vous venez d'annoncer une augmentation
du point d'indice de la fonction
publique de 1,5% applicable au 1er
juillet prochain ainsi que des mesures
complémentaires prime facultatives ou
augmentation du nombre de points pour
les agents de catégorie B et C en 2024
dans le contexte de fortes inflation que
nous connaissons nous ne pouvons que
nous en réjouir cette augmentation
constituera un coup de pouce dont les
agents publics ont le plus grand besoin
pour soutenir leur pouvoir d'achat cette
annonce intervient cependant à une
époque de l'année où les budgets des
communes ont déjà été votés début jets
déjà contraints et avec parfois des
augmentations d'impôts décidé pour faire
face et continuer d'investir
certaines communes n'ont eu
communication de la part de leur
fournisseurs d'énergie du montant de
leur facture d'électricité du premier
trimestre qu'après le vote de leur
budget avec parfois des augmentations
substantielles dans mon département même
avec les boucliers tarifaires elles
peuvent être de l'ordre de 40%. en un
mot nos villes et nos villages surtout
n'ont plus une image budgétaire ni
perspective dans ces conditions on le
sait sans aide c'est l'équilibre des
budgets qui est remis en cause et va
compromettre leur investissement et leur
projet
faute de moyens d'amorce de ces projets
les collectivités de mots ne pourront
prétendre aux aides des etr des cils
fond vert ou autres subventions les élus
on le sentiment qu'on reprend d'un côté
ce que l'on donne de l'autre monsieur le
ministre ma question est donc simple
l'augmentation du point d'indice de la
fonction publique étant une décision
d'État l'état va-t-il compenser comme
cela a été fait même partiellement dans
la loi de finances rectificative en août
2022 enfin comment avez-vous et allez
vous consulter les associations d'élus
c'est élu qui sont encore et toujours en
première ligne dans nos territoires